to
be who you are
be human and not to hide
your personal life and i think when you
are honest about who you are people
embrace it and embrace you
and understand you welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking to miriam mark about sales
marketing and revenue
meet miriam the cro of compete a company
revolutionizing the world of hr tech
prior to that as an executive member of
the core sales teams that we work she
was instrumental in building their
global sales organization from
acquisition to retention and growth
miriam began her career at shopping.com
an online comparison shopping company
which was acquired by ebay
prior to her current position she led
sales at farmigo an online farmers
market with a mission to transform and
accelerate global adoption of an
alternative food system
before entering the business world
miriam was an educator and that passion
drives the training of her teams in all
her positions
miriam lives with her husband ari and
their four children ages 7 to 16 in los
angeles california
miriam mark welcome to 20 minute leaders
from los angeles thank you so much for
joining me here how are you
i'm good thanks for having me
we have way too many things to talk
about uh in these 20 minutes miriam a
fascinating incredible background all
the way from sales associated shopping
to to continuing your your sales and
specifically enterprise
journey and being one of the core
members core founding members of the
wework enterprise sales team and growing
the company with for farmigo in between
also and an advisor to some fantastic
companies like emilio and show fields
two companies that i hold very dear to
my heart vice president of sales at ramp
and most recently the chief revenue
officer of compete also a company that
that is doing incredible things for the
world and for the workplace in general
miriam thank you so much for for coming
here and and i have to start off with
with the simple question of what was
this all planned were you know how how
do you find yourself in a position where
you're
spending meaningful time at such
incredible companies in hyper growth
stages
when i was in college i interned at
shopping.com which at the time was not
called shopping.com it's called deal
time and i worked there a bunch of
semesters and afterwards they hired me
full time to be a sales associate which
was an entry level position
and i will never forget on my first day
i got on a call with what was a watch
company in florida
and it was a cpc sale and i closed the
deal on the first call and i was bitten
by the sales bug it was the most
euphoric feeling to close the sales deal
and that was it for me
except so i did that for about a year
and a half and then my husband looked at
me we were living in new york at the
time
newly married and he looks at me and he
says
what do you think about living in los
angeles and i said i don't think about
it at all actually because i wanted to
move to israel and the next thing i know
i'm on a plane moving to los angeles
with tears in my eyes thinking how has
this happened to me and at the time i
was thinking well what will i do now i
mean obviously i love selling but
i my heart is in israel and my family is
in israel and i really want to do
something that'll make it easy to go to
israel all the time
and so i became a teacher actually
and i
taught middle school girls judaic
studies because i thought oh summer
vacation i can go to israel and all the
jewish holidays i can go to israel and i
did it and i actually was pretty good at
it i connected with the kids and i
enjoyed the curriculum
and about five years in i kind of looked
at myself and said what are you doing
this is not your passion and when you're
not doing it as a passion you're
cheating the kids so i left and went
back into sales and i remembered my true
passion was really in sales and business
and that's kind of how i got back into
it and and interestingly
um when i look back now and this was
again not the real
plan it lent itself very well because
when you need to train sales teams and
you need to build a curriculum really
around sales training having done that
lent itself actually quite well to my
story but it was not my plan
incredible what what is sales
to you you mentioned that euphoric
feeling of closing that first sale but
if you're looking now you know looking
back at the different organizations
you've been a part of and you've seen
both the
the sale itself but you've also seen us
an organizational sale
what is it in essence
it's an amazing question and it's one
that i ask every single person i
interview for any sales job
okay everybody this is this one word
this is it this is the key uh to whether
or not you should hire someone there's
one word i look for in that answer and
it's
listening to me that's what sales is
because if you don't listen to their
needs you can't sell them anything
and if you don't deeply understand it's
called active listening
what somebody is looking for or their
pain points you can't sell them anything
so to me that's what sales is just
listening to people
okay so so listening active listening
looking at your your career now what i
would really love is to sort of find
some meaningful milestones for you
in your journey and now as you're the
chief revenue officer of compete sort of
looking back at this journey what are
some things that you've learned about
either enterprise sales or growing sales
organizations that weren't trivial to
you before
that young entrepreneurs like myself can
learn from
for me
so i think it's different for everyone
and i think some people find a mentor
and that person just takes them along
and helps them figure it out
that was not my story
for me
it was
um i had i had the benefit of knowing
people who helped me kind of find this
job or that job and get my foot in the
door
um a lot of it was grit i had a lot of
grit and i um
would kind of
figure myself out in an organization so
in every organization there was a moment
where
i
so at firmigo i was just like a lone
salesperson and then there was a pivot
in the company and i showed that i could
build a sales team
and i was good at it and so i did it and
then there was the moment where
um i'm very loyal it's just a
personality trait and i could have
stayed there forever but there was that
moment when we came
up and i had the opportunity to move and
then i i showed myself and i'm i'm i'm
talented at sales and i
um
i hit milestones along the way and
because i was um
able to
hire people or or able to
um
make
inroads for myself i think i think for
me the milestones came because i i put
the stakes in the ground i did things
um
and i almost made my own milestones and
i don't know if that answers your
question or not
um but i think a lot of it is
um just doing and making waves yourself
and not relying on on other people and
that is
the advice i would give people
but you looking at looking at you know
your your milestone making and creating
this waves for yourself and obviously
learning by doing proving your value and
then you know doing so obviously you
know looking at your trajectory it's uh
it it makes a lot of sense
how does that process work for you
you're sitting down and you're saying
now either as a sales associate or
as a hyper growth company
how do you even know what milestones to
set and where to aim yourself so that
you're both
satisfied but also not
upset that you didn't necessarily reach
those uncompromising milestones that you
set for yourself
that's a really hard question to answer
um
i think you
have to
aim high
so you set the milestone you aim higher
than
what you where you want to land
so i can fly
i always
aimed higher and it doesn't mean i
wasn't disappointed if i didn't get to
what i aimed for but at least i landed
someplace
that i could be proud of
right right
miriam what where's the fun
in
in your in your work
i'm looking at you know sales associates
and maybe it's because i watched too
much of the office even though it was
obvious that they had a lot of fun
selling paper it's my son's favorite
show he's watching like six times he has
a fantastic taste where is what what is
the what what is the fun moment beyond
just the the closing the sale especially
in the building is sales organization
what's going on there
i love building high functioning sales
organizations i love hiring people i
love mentoring people i love watching
people get to the next level and for
everyone that level is something
different somebody might want to be an
individual contributor forever
and somebody might want to become a
manager and then a director and maybe a
cro i mean i'd love nothing more than to
see someone take my job
but i love helping people reach their
goals
i love building infrastructure it's
funny i just got off a call with someone
and she told me where she used to work
infrastructure was a dirty word but to
me
if you don't put infrastructure in place
everything falls apart i love doing that
um i'm at compete now and i'm having the
best time just putting
everything in place
i love working with great people i love
nothing more than that
i want to go to work every day
where i work with amazing people and
it's actually why i chose compete
because i'm working with amazing people
i i love it and they
really are amazing people
and advice for me now as a young
entrepreneur and for all the other young
entrepreneurs you know running running
our companies
how do how should we as
we are sales people inherently selling
our vision and continuously but but as
we're transitioning to build a sales
function
within our organizations what are some
things that i as a young entrepreneur
perhaps um oblivious to or maybe i'm
taking for granted that you understand
now is is much more meaningful than what
i can anticipate
i just gave this advice to a friend
who's
founded a business
hire a great sales leader
don't think that you can sell your
product yourself
because you can't do everything if
you're the ceo
you need to put a team in place
i think that that's sometimes a mistake
ceos make
um that's one piece of advice also
everyone's a salesperson in the
organization everyone should always be
selling your engineers or sales people
your
data people are sales people everyone's
a sales person and everyone should
always be thinking about the customer in
every role customer is number one
customer customer number one well i'm
definitely and i'm still thinking back
to to the active listening portion as to
what what it what is sales in general
but miriam right right before we started
talking here with with the big red
recording flashing you mentioned that
that
part of the journey also which is
non-trivial here
that that should also not be definitely
not be taken for granted is also the the
personal journey that is accompanying
the the professional one and in in our
world they're always intertwining and
it's been a topic of discussion in
recent years but definitely not enough
a little bit about
yourself
as a mother running these organizations
i can't imagine as you're with wework
and you're
in this hyper growth stage or today with
compete in one of the top companies
coming out of israel today it can't be
easy you know managing personal and
professional life at the same time
i'm a mom i have four children my oldest
son has special needs it's a big part of
what defines me
um i have always been 100 comfortable
talking about my family
talking about my son with special needs
everybody knows i have one and i think
it's really important
to
be who you are
be human
and not to hide
your personal life and i think when you
are honest about who you are people
embrace it and embrace you
and understand you
i have had a lot of emergencies over the
years i've never
pretended not to have them and i've
never hidden from them but at the same
time i've never compromised myself as a
professional
i used to travel for rework all the time
there were many many weeks that i got on
a plane on monday night and didn't come
back till thursday night and that was
the reality of our life in those days we
picked up and moved our family to new
york for two years
for an opportunity at wework
and that was mommy's job and i think
it's important for kids to see that
mommy works
and that's okay too and so it's just
been a part of who i am always i've
encouraged women to
understand that it's not about work-life
balance it's about i always say this
sometimes i'm the greatest mom and
sometimes i'm the greatest boss and
sometimes i'm the worst at everything
and i've learned to forgive myself in
those moments and that's the advice i
give to working women you can't be great
at everything and i don't know who
decided we should be that's very silly
and sometimes i go into the shower and
cry and that's how i solve my problems
and that's okay too and you shouldn't be
ashamed of that and i really exercise a
lot and that's how i find balance
because i take it out on the streets of
la or on my yoga mat
and i i think that
it's really important
to be okay with who you are and in the
world somehow i think today
people have not
found it acceptable
to be honest about who you are but you
can be a cro at a company and be a mom
and
that's fine
and i'm proud of it
what are the
the consequences of positive
consequences
of of being that authentic of being that
open especially in an environment which
until today you know it's in general the
the world around us is not that
forgiving for this type of authenticity
how does this come back at you
in whatever structure you're in whether
it's a company a school daily life etc
first of all i really appreciate that
you were used the word authentic because
that's the number one way i describe
myself so thank you for noticing it
uh that there have been quite a few at
my kid's school people used to say oh
you're here
do you even live here i used to get that
all the time
at work i got passed over
many many times i mean i think it's well
known that one of the places i worked
women did not have the same
opportunities as men
i've been underpaid
as opposed to my male peers which makes
me really proud of the work we do at
compete to be honest i think that we
are doing something amazing
i
sat in
a room many many times while we
interviewed
for a vp of sales role
and every time a female came up
they said oh does she have children will
she be able to travel
and i sat there and thought to myself i
have four and i travel every week
so
there have been consequences but
at the same time there have been
positives right i've had the chance to i
created the maternity leave policy for
women in sales at wework and it was
amazing
and people have looked up to me and i've
counseled so many women on what it is to
be a working woman and
i've had women come over to me and say
wow i want to be you when i grow up
and how do i
aspire to be like you and so i'm i'm
i see both sides of the coin
and i now i get to work with amit and
who is more incredible than her and it's
the first time i've had a female boss
uh and worked with a female entrepreneur
and it's incredible
i love it this is this is so cool miriam
what does the chief revenue officer do
what is what what is your responsibility
now within
this rocket ship that is compete
uh today i'm building a sales and
marketing organization
that means i'm building all the
infrastructure for sales everything from
what are the metrics
uh
commission plans hiring all the sales
people hiring a marketing team
i'm trying to figure out what our goals
should be i'm trying to figure out how
we get from you know one round to the
next round
that's just
this week
i'm hiring so if people are looking for
jobs they should listen to this podcast
and hopefully apply i have a lot of open
roles uh leadership roles i see roles we
have everything
and as you're this is not the first time
you're hiring i've seen you manage
mentioned what would be something that
you're looking for
in a in an active listener for for a
sales representative but but and i can
see a theme here in this conversation
that that you know there is the work
part where and you have to be
professional you have to set high
standards and high goals but there's a
much deeper meaning here for the people
that you choose to work with and the
people that you choose to work for and
it sounds like your transition to
compete was also pretty intentional in
that regard
what is the type of person that you're
looking to work for what what are what
what does this person embody in their
day-to-day
that i that i'm looking for on my team
yeah
so number one active listeners
i look for people who can relate to
customers and
i look for chameleons meaning
whoever the customer is you can
be relatable to them and
relate to them
i look for people
who
are authentic
i don't i'm not interested in mercenary
salespeople for my team that has a place
in the sales world just not
on my sales team
i look for people who
are able to
understand their weaknesses this is a
really big deal for me i ask a question
that's very uh focused for this
do you understand your strengths and
weaknesses and you know how to play to
your strengths
and not to your weaknesses and that's a
very big deal for me
um
you know obviously have you achieved
quota in the past and all of that but
for me it's much more about the other
things that i mentioned
miriam this was such a an energizing and
an amazing conversation thank you very
very much and
i am reflecting back on my own
authenticity and and how
big a part i want this to play in my
life and and the steps that i think i
need to do definitely and so many people
in the world need to do to first own up
to who we are and in and out of the
workplace and you give the example i
think of you know being a mother but i
think that all of us have our own things
that we're carrying with us where
whatever it may be
that i may be hiding from people around
me or maybe downplaying it or up playing
it and and and i saw this conversation
is going to leave me thinking a lot and
i think it resonates with anybody
listening here so thank you very very
much i appreciate your time and your
effort best of luck with compete and my
regards to amit and the best of luck in
this amazing rocketship and the journey
and thank you very much
thank you so much for having me i really
enjoyed the conversation thank you
[Music]